a green yak hair that turned inward and
went crying
it was horrifying it's not every day the
cia is brought in to help an actor deal
with torture
today we're taking a look at the crazy
things actors and crews went through on
sets
which crew is secretly drugged with pcp
how about the actor who was kidnapped on
their way back to set
let's check out these wild stories i
opened up my door
and i saw a couple of ambulances pulling
in filming titanic was an intense
experience for all involved
especially the day when over 60 people
were accidentally drugged by chowder
yes we're talking about soup one crew
member was so over director james
cameron that he spiked the chowder for
the casting crew with pcp
a drug that caused everyone who'd
consumed the soup to have intense
hallucinations
cameron was so disoriented that he
couldn't even find his way out of the
set that he'd just spent the last four
weeks filming in
and then he was stabbed in the face with
a pen by a crew member
meanwhile cast and crew members were
racing each other in wheelchairs and
doing a conga line while they were
riding their high in the hospital
now i'm starting to witness some bizarre
behavior keep in mind
this was all happening in the middle of
the night because their lunch break
was around midnight to this day there
has never been confirmation as to who
actually spiked the chowder
i don't know who did it or why when
cumberbatch was filming to the ends of
the earth he ran
to a bit of trouble driving back to set
with two friends
they thought a flat tire was the worst
of their troubles until
the group wound up being kidnapped at
gunpoint
surrounded by these guys pulled back
into the car driven off road
they knew they were in a dangerous area
but had no idea that they'd be facing
six kidnappers who tied them up so
tightly that cumberbatch reported he
started losing sensation in his limbs
so it was truly one of the most
terrifying experiences of my life
the grinch is as bitter as can be and
with good reason
i did the makeup 100 times in order to
deal with the pain of transforming into
the grinch
the production team for how the grinch
stole christmas actually brought in
cia operatives to help jim carrey the
actor had said his costume made him feel
like he was being buried alive
first day was eight and a half hours and
i told ron howard i couldn't do the
movie
so specialists from the cia trained in
how to endure torture
helped gary learn how to endure so he
could get through shooting the film
when filming youth and revolt justin
long suffered a similar fate to that of
the drug titanic cast
he'd gotten another drug that also
happened to be laced with pcp
rendering invulnerable enough to be
kidnapped what exactly did the
kidnappers want with justin long
they threatened to film the actor while
he was rolling to release it to tmz
hoping to cause some kind of scandal
long wanted
nothing to do with it and actually ended
up escaping by jumping out of a vehicle
and suffering nerve damage in his leg as
a result
joseph gordon-levitt had a very close
call when he was filming premium rush
playing the dangerous and daring role of
a bike messenger
the actor was biking through cars at 30
miles per hour which is
actually pretty speedy for a bike a taxi
had driven over the safety cones and cut
gordon levitt off so bad that the actor
flew
off into the back of the taxi's
windshield and sliced his forearm
the crew was terrified watching what
happened on the monitors and genuinely
thought that they'd lost the actor
just emotionally you know it wasn't
going to be better for them without the
battlefield
the batmobile looks pretty out there so
much so that a drunk driver mistook
it for an alien spacecraft one night the
man in question didn't have a license
and was struck with panic seeing what he
thought was an alien attack
so his first instinct was to speed
towards it and bang up batman's car
at one point during filming for x-men
origins wolverine
hugh jackman had to run down a hallway
in the nude wearing nothing but prop
claws on his hands
first day of x-men origins i read naked
i seem to i quite enjoy it really
he'd come around the corner and much to
his surprise
every woman on the production team was
waiting for him waving dollar bills
around jokingly
to cover his business jackman used the
claws but because they were so
sharp he actually wound up cutting
himself obviously it's pg-13 so
you can't have bits and pieces flying
about right the revenant was an intense
filming experience for everyone involved
and while leonardo dicaprio dove into
his method acting
the whole cast was forced to experience
intense isolation and disconnect from
the rest of the world
since there was absolutely no service in
alberta canada
where they were shooting in order to
receive and send any messages the team
had no choice but to actually snowmobile
back and forth from set to a place with
some reception
we it was very tough but we knew that we
were
signing on for something very
experimental very different
ryan reynolds probably became very
nervous before filming the amityville
horror remake
when just a few days before they began a
body had washed up onto the shore
right by their set and then a dead body
surfaced
in the lake which was interesting this
was probably the first indicator that
the production was cursed
the second was when reynolds and other
cast members began constantly waking up
at 3
15 am what makes this particular time
especially creepy
is that it's the time the real-life
amityville horror happened
the light's turning on the middle of the
house one night and nobody was in there
and the guards were called
the wizard of oz set wasn't so wonderful
for the actors
the scarecrow aka ray bolger had such
intense makeup on that it actually left
permanent damage marks all over the
lower half of his face
judy garland didn't have a grade either
probably starving the whole time since
she was kept on a diet of chicken soup
black coffee diet pills and four packs
of cigarettes a day
so many movies are filled with cgi
nowadays but christopher nolan wanted a
real farm for interstellar the crew
planted over 800 acres of corn
he wanted to show corn was being farmed
in a place that shouldn't be
and since they were filming in calgary
alberta that was definitely the case
and the corn didn't even last alan
rickman wasn't hesitant to put some
pretty drastic measures in place for
matthew lewis and rupert grint when
filming harry potter in the order of the
phoenix
rickman had banned the boys from coming
within even five feet of his new bmw
since they'd spilled milkshakes in his
old par let's talk about mclovin
when mint's place was filming superbad
he had to perform this intimate scene
but the actor was only 17 at the time
mins plus his mother had to be present
on set while they filmed that particular
bit
very awkward what made it worse for the
actor was the fact that he was still a
virgin at the time
his mom had to watch him work through
and figure it all out in front of a
whole crew of people
how was it for his mom well she had a
pretty great experience
laughing eating popcorn and talking to
producers on set
you know me right tom felton was
notorious for sneaking candy on to set
in his costumes
while he may have thought he was being
stealthy the crew did notice and after
the prisoner of azkaban
the costume department sewed up pockets
on all the costumes
many of the other young witches and
wizards had begun sneaking food onto set
following felton's not so stealthy lee
talk about strict measures i'm trying to
say that something is coming
when filming avengers infinity war the
cast made good use of their down time
they actually got together and made a
music video
however it's never seen the light of day
because the cast thought it was far too
embarrassing to
actually be released especially for mark
ruffalo
according to anthony mackie they were
halfway through the process
and then they realized just how bad they
all were at dancing and since no one
else would
they felt it was best the whole venture
just be put to rest
who knew how intense bringing these
productions to life was for some actors
and crews
we're pretty impressed with how well
they performed despite some insane
conditions what we are definitely hoping
to see soon
is a leaked copy of that avengers music
video